so i have a few quick questions before
jumping into your series um
uh if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
for me i think wayne's world
um
because it's the first movie i ever did
um
and uh
i want them to see the bohemian rhapsody
sequence there there i said it yeah for
me i did a wonky show called look around
you which i'm very proud of and uh it
sort of went out in the bbc and no one
saw it um but i'm very proud of it and
it's it's lovely because
people in the states and the uk
um comedy fans find stuff they know
stuff so it's always lovely when someone
comes up and goes i love look around you
and even though it's 20 years ago comedy
and jaws and uh
in many ways
the pentavera for me was
is almost like the the it's an extension
of look around you in the sense it's
world building it's original it's
finding areas of comedy that haven't
been explored yet so
yeah so so that's that's for me that's
my look around you is
a comic masterpiece i bless you i've
been hunting him
uh like the animal that he is
uh for many many years trying to find
some way to to us to do something
together and he finally said yes and
here we are so i'm thrilled i bet steve
you're googling it now right now right
just oh
no not at all i've uh i haven't seen it
but i have heard of it um it's impo like
it's impossible for me to have seen
everything just you know what i mean
it's um this is what we call a lot of
content yes
right it's you know but i just figured
out how you guys came to be working
together um so uh mike just an
individual question um you won't
remember this but i interviewed you for
the love guru 14 years ago yes um and
it's been a very obviously a long time
since you've starred in something um
like this uh was there another project
that you came close to doing or was this
the first thing that really pulled you
in
many but uh to be honest with you uh
my son i got married
12 years ago
um my son was born
10 years ago and i spent the last 10
years
uh raising three kids
under the age of 10 obviously um i've
done a lot of projects that didn't take
me away from home that was my number one
so when i did super mensch the the
documentary on shep gordon i did it out
of my house the editing equipment was in
my apartment in new york
um
you know
i got to see my kids in the morning
and if they wanted to see daddy all they
had to do was go down one floor you know
what i mean because i had an office
below
our apartment
um and then i did inglorious bastards
which small part and a quentin tarantino
film playing a british general which was
of course a dream come true
and bohemian rhapsody
oh god i did uh
the gong show which uh so i had the
whole family come out i did two seasons
of that that was only like three weeks
that was the good news so i wasn't away
from the family
and then i'd say about two years ago i
kelly said you know i think you have the
whole three kids thing down
you i think there's i think there's a
series in you because i was just
obsessed with secret societies
and she said you should pitch that dude
i think that's a something and so about
two years ago and then we had the covey
year of course but maybe it was three
years ago now because you always have to
add one year for covet whenever you
think something happened sure and i went
in and i said to uh i said to netflix
what if five people ran the world
but what if they were nice what if i
played all five people and they said
yeah sounds great
and this is what i love about netflix
and i went okay
and then i hunted him down he was my
first the first thing i did was hunt
down tim kirk and then i said what if
there was five directors and they were
all [ __ ]
no i didn't um
yeah and you know it was a great for me
it was a great union i think you know
with
television and film you have to find
your warriors you have to find the
people
who
are similar to how you feel and how you
think
creatively
uh because it's a long journey it's a
long process and
and you grow an idea and you form it and
you push it you nudge it and you have to
find the right people and that's why
some projects work and some don't
because you know it's very very hard you
know we don't know if it's gonna work we
we if it makes us laugh and we and you
know mike's career is
uh shows that
he's very connected to
what he does he's craft so
if it's making us laugh then hell yes
let's put it down and shoot it and see
what happens and then yeah and it sort
of
you approached me a couple of years ago
yes because i knew that what tim would
do
like all good creators is he would agree
an ad
which is the essence of the creative
experience and
what tim also understood was that
anything you do is what del close from
second city talked about is
is a transformative
thing so there's so much of tim kirkby
in this show that
was him saying well what if
and then it was crazy
man yeah what if man yeah what if
and uh when you see episode five and six
that's where
the craziness of tim
when he went i was just thinking mike
and then you're like we can't do that he
goes well why not i'm like
yeah
this is what i love about working with
english people
is that
the
in north america the subjects
fit for comedy
are
this
in england
it's that and in england they demand of
their their creators that it be fresh
you know what i mean and they're
suspicious of the familiar
and it's kind of the inverse in north
america so i knew this was an english
style limited series
and i had seen his work and loved it and
i met with him and i went ah kelly is my
wife i said he
gets it he gets it i don't have to
explain anything he's a brother from
another mother and we're both liamies
you know what i mean yeah i have to ask
you these are
what i consider minor very minor
spoilers um whose idea was it for the
hulk theme with sasquatch you mean this
the barnic man right six million dollars
oh i'm so sorry it is the balletic man
i'm so sorry that's my bad
yes
yeah similar well that was you that was
me i've been obsessed with uh i i so
i've been obsessed with the
and tried to put it in everything that
i've ever done to be honest
and tim of course is obsessed with
sasquatch obsessed and so we would write
a scene and then tim goes to why
sasquatch could be in it
okay not not really tim
i mean just in the background now tim
can you not be smoking and i'm thinking
tim like
is sasquatch one of your clients or
something like
so i i have a gift for you but didn't
didn't make the plane no
is it is it
no it's better it's sasquatch themed
hello
what a lucky english but i am yes i
can't wait
was it tough getting billy eilish to get
give you the song in the credits of
episode four she was fantastic
this was this whole show was a festival
of yes
it was an orgy of agreement
so many people
just said yes and showed up it felt like
stone soup you know yeah
just everybody just
came to play kim jong-un yeah it's a
very playful project you know it's very
different it's very exciting i think you
know there's a lot of love for mike and
i think
you know people
heard the sort of the pitch where i'm in
i'm in i'm in i don't care i mean
so we had the luxury of um dreaming up
actors and situations and writing
scenarios and dreaming up
uh
you know moments to
to welcome that because it felt very
playful um creative and very open as
well and that's just work with mike just
he is very open so
we it's very it's sort of quite
sort of just
there's no wrong idea there's no it's
not yes or no there's a consequence of
an idea but at least there's an idea
yeah and then we shoot it you don't know
if an idea is going to work or not you
can't kill it in the crib you know what
i mean
you have to let it do its thing it tells
you if it's going to live or not you
shouldn't tell it yeah and that's the
great thing of working with tim is that
it's like yeah man it's trying
and i'm going to be doing an impression
of you all day i'm afraid i can't
i love it
but um
i'm american really playing a brit it's
remarkable he's amazing character and
getting away with it for 20 years but
um
if you're in a place of yes and you
can't go wrong
yeah
i have to stop i just want to thank both
of you for making me laugh uh and i hope
it's a big hit for you guys and thank
you so much for your time oh my god
thank you so much thank you thank you
very much
you